we come to a red light and i stop
and i look at her
she's looking straight ahead
and i said rosario
is everything okay
you haven't said a word
best piece of advice you've ever
received simple question i realize it
but
i mean it's profound but it's not
profound
um
we talked earlier you know in my in in
my past
uh in san francisco i was a criminal
defense lawyer and it was an absolutely
brilliant experience the people that i
met the things i was exposed to the
community that i served
it you know if i've often said if our if
our life is a book that was one of the
best chapters i'll ever know
it wasn't necessarily my calling in the
sense that it was a perfect fit for my
temperament
i didn't want to do it into well into my
adulthood but i'm so grateful for it it
taught me a lot
when that came to a close and i knew the
day it came to a close it was i was done
um
i was very nervous because
the person i most admire my hero my best
friend was my dad and i had to go now
tell my dad
not just that i was quitting a job but
that i was quitting a career because i
really didn't want to be an attorney
beyond
that choice that i had made
so i went to my dad and we i pulled him
out of his business and we got to go
have a bite or
something a drink
and um
and we sat down at this place and i was
so nervous
what was his reaction going to be and
finally
i said dad you know
we're here because
there's something really important i
want to
share with you
he said what is it i said well you know
i'm gonna i'm quitting my job
and i'm quitting the law
it's
not what i want to do
and literally in that moment my father
without missing a beat smiled
something was already wrong
he smiled and he looked at me and he
said that's great
and i was just like stunned it was like
i expect parental lecture number what
have you about the investment of time
and money and this is respectable and
all those
typical things
and i and i said dad i just that's not
what i expected
and i actually asked him why why do you
say that why is it great
and he said because
i don't think you've been happy
and i think you should go find what
excites you and whatever that is
i think that's what you should go do
it was like the the utter simplicity
and heart
and humanity of that moment as simple as
that statement was i was just
cowed
it like took me to my knees it was like
oh my god
i know that you're wise i know that
you're an amazing dad
but you've just upped the game
and that's what i would say to people
and the other is a quote which i'm going
to read because i don't want to get it
wrong it's from i mean after all you
don't want to misquote william faulkner
of all people
so william faulconer had this wonderful
quote that i've always loved always
dream and shoot higher than you know you
can do
don't bother just to be better than your
contemporaries or your predecessors
try to be better than yourself
that's the game
you know it's that like 100-day thing
every day i'm going to wake up and i
just want to be one percent better than
the me that was yesterday
were you working for a firm
i was working as a lawyer
it was a
foundation in
in what was the ghetto of san francisco
it was called baby hunters point
so there was the baby hunters point
foundation
that
um
about
125 people
in the center was the sort of linchpin
the sexy sort of fundraising piece which
was criminal defense
so we represented the indigent adults of
that geography in lieu of the public
defender they were ours
and then we had alongside that
we had the the social workers and we had
the
drug rehabilitation program and we had
the job skills retraining program and we
had all of these the investigators we
had
the idea was a holistic
solution for this
beautiful community that was very
beleaguered in many ways
keep the families together the kids in
school the guys out of jail etc
and um
our chief counsel
was named richard bancroft
richard bancroft
i was so intimidated by this man when we
first met baso profundo voice tall
good-looking african-american older
a civil rights leader in the south
before lbj coined the phrase civil
rights
he'd been a president a national
president of the naacp he'd seen
life that i couldn't even imagine
and he was our chief counsel and then we
had a few attorneys and then a couple of
schlubs like me
but then we had all these other services
these human services to serve this
beautiful community
and for a kid who really had never spent
time in the projects or in the criminal
justice system certainly it was
eye-opening
and it was a perfect it was a perfect
it was a perfect dance it was a perfect
marriage for me at that time
these people became my family they
became my teachers
i learned more in my very first year of
interning for them than i learned in
three years of law school
it was
extraordinary
yeah
they're still there
did you see pursuit of happiness because
that takes place in san francisco
correct yeah yeah yeah
yeah great film great story excellent um
yeah extraordinary real story
yeah yeah it was it was um
you know as they said the best of times
the worst of times
i loved i loved i loved every day that i
spent there
and
emotionally
i was a wreck almost every night
yeah that's i wasn't i wasn't built for
criminal defense
i couldn't separate
you know i wasn't a great chess player
i wore it on my sleeve a little bit
sure
yeah
but again it gives you just insane
levels of appreciation for how
diverse
this life experience can be
and
just the unexpected challenges and joys
you know like that was one of the most
joyful communities i've ever experienced
in my life
do you ever go back i'm sure has it been
gentrified by now maybe um
yes and no not really i mean it's it's
it's such a physically
uh it's it's it's literally across the
bridge to get to you don't go there
unless you mean to go there
so when when i say it's segregated i
mean it like literally physically is
its own distinct area
um out by the old shipyards
but the truth is i could be wrong
because you know
precious as land is let alone in san
francisco maybe it's been gentrified i
haven't been up you know harlem's been
gentrified maybe maybe a hundred flight
been gentrified i haven't been up to see
it in
oh god
i don't know 15 years
or more
yeah
so you had the lunch with your dad
he gave you his blessing so to speak
even though you already had this plan
and then you
gave your notice or you had already
given your notice at that time
um
i had i i had let people know it wasn't
like i walked in
gave my notice and walked out the door
these were family
it was really heart-wrenching for me to
leave
[Music]
but yeah i couldn't not and there were
some personal things that went on that
that just made it impossible for me to
be doing that work
um
but it was like uh
yeah you know
when i went to law school i went to
golden gate university law school which
was actually directly across the street
from my dad's place of business and
everybody knew my dad and it was like it
was
just so perfect anyway
my first year of law school i met a gal
who was in my class
she was
probably about my age back then
single mom
two boys
msw degree and a private social work
practice that was hers oh wow
and she was a full-time first year law
student
rosario
her name was rosario
african-american big personality
smart as a whip
and i remember being at first like you
know
i i didn't approach her because she was
like superwoman right how do you have an
msw and two kids and be a full-time law
student and just
how is that possible
well we did become friends
and one day she approached me
halfway through our first year i think
it was and she said gary you you know i
know you've i hear you've worked out at
baby hunters point and you know you're
close to the
to them
um
i'd love to
meet them
can i go out there with you sometime and
i said of course absolutely
so i took her out on
every tuesday was staff meeting day when
everybody's there and i said let's go on
a tuesday y'all you'll meet everybody
so i took her out
introduced her we walked in introduced
everybody schmoozed away you know got
into the staff meeting came out
schmoozed with everybody hung out made
sure she met everybody who was there
um and said i loved being there i wasn't
in a hurry to leave anyway finally
it's time to go we got my little carmen
gear volkswagen to head back to downtown
san francisco
uh
and drop her off late afternoon
so
suffice to say rosario was not a shy
retiring wallflower she was
she was full of life
we get in my car and i start driving
[Music]
and i've been driving now for several
minutes and she hasn't uttered a
syllable
we come to a red light and i stop
and i look at her
she's looking straight ahead
and i said rosario
is everything okay
you haven't said a word
and privately i never experienced that
right
she turned and she looked at me and very
slowly
she said
those people
really love you
and it took me a minute for
the dimension of that to sink in right
it was it was i think she was a bit
surprised by the dimension of our
relationship
um
and i say i tell you that i share that
anecdote um
really to describe how meaningful that
was to me and how hard it was to leave
them it wasn't hard to leave the
practice of law at all
but it was hard to leave the
people
um
but i will say this just much like being
a kid in the 60s in san francisco and
being at uc berkeley in the heyday and
putting on the kind you know and then
that experience that baby hunters those
are all
related
in the you know in the daisy chain of my
life
those are all pivotal moments that
really have
everything to do with forming my world
view
how i see things what i care about
it was a extraordinary time i was very
i'm still to this day grateful that i
have the history that i have
you know pretty cool
pretty blessed
and here we are in hollywood
not bad
excited for
i don't know i think i i think we're at
a really exciting moment
like that for me
when the studios became
purchased
and you know but then he bought
universal and sony black colombia et
cetera et cetera et cetera and they
became populated with a different
group of people
and the budgets went up in the 20
million star and all those things align
with the demise of
the indies
so there's
i don't know 25 or more
robust companies that were putting out
as many films if not more than the
studios collectively right
um who were either broken up with their
library value or just went bankrupt or
whatever happened right so the hemdales
and
and and the vestrons and all of those
wonderful companies and
suddenly there was no independent cinema
the studios became more corporate they
made half as many phones with double the
size budgets and
there was this contraction moment
and it was it's a time when i started to
take walkabouts and do other things
alongside
this thing called producing
and suddenly in because of what's
happened in recent years we now have
something that is so much more robust
than that ever was the demand for story
is the
the the size of the appetite and the
number of series and films that are that
are needed and being and actually being
you know be coveted aside the
obviously production's been quashed for
the year but
but the number of projects that are
being developed and produced overall
for all of these streamers
who have a lot of diverse appetites to
feed
it's absolutely
stunning to me
and i think it's a great time to refocus
our energies and you know be in the game
and figure out this
this new landscape
you